all right so now that Barbarian is on
HBO Max we gotta talk about this banana
sandwich Bonkers horror film that had my
jaw on the ground a handful of times and
was a roller coaster of uh what what is
happening 2022 has been a great year for
horror let's just say that but in this
video we're going to be breaking down
the story explain that ending along with
touching on some of the themes and
messages cleverly tucked away in
Barbarian now if you enjoy this video
then hit that like button as it helps
the channel and prevents the creature in
the basement from snatching you up and
also don't forget to subscribe for
breakdowns Recaps and other videos like
this every day with that out of the way
a huge thank you for clicking this now
let's get into this video
foreign
[Music]
so much like the movie we're going to be
breaking this thing down in sections
with the movie's three-act structure
being the perfect template the First Act
opens on faint screams along with our
main character of Tess as it's quickly
established that she has been caught in
a frustrating nightmare of being double
booked at an Airbnb with Pennywise the
Clown you know Bill Skarsgard who is
Keith in this situation the two try to
come to a mutual solution in a funny uh
who's on first type of conversation
settling on both staying the night at
the rental Tess gets the bedroom while
Keith takes the couch there's an uneasy
almost stranger danger tension between
the two of them as Tess ignores the tea
that Keith makes for and Keith goes on
an awkwardly long ramble about how like
not opening the wine until she was there
because he didn't want to feel weird and
he wanted her to make her feel safe
through conversation though Tess lets
her guard down as they find
commonalities and and then call it a
night however two things seem a bit off
as Tess's locked door is wide open and
the basement door slowly closes in the
background
the next day Tess notices that the house
is the only livable one in the entire
neighborhood and after her interview a
homeless man staggers out of the
run-down neighborhood telling her to
come out of that house it's not safe and
boy was this man right because Tess
discovers a hidden room after
unfortunately locking herself in the
basement the worst Casting Couch
audition room I have ever seen with a
bed frame camcorder and bloody handprint
freaked out Tess frantically tells Keith
they need to go something isn't right
here only for him to Discount whatever
she's saying and investigate himself
this constant disregard of what Tess
says combined with a male ego is a theme
that pops up more and more as the story
progresses here Keith goes into the
basement despite Tess's warning and
while the night before Tess also
mentions that if the roles had been
reversed where she was in the rental and
Keith was actually outside he would have
just stopped right into the Airbnb
without a second thought that men can
blast their way through life while women
have to be a bit more cautious Keith has
heard screaming for help as Tess cannot
stand by discovering yet another door as
the underground Labyrinth goes even
deeper and maybe it was the way it was
shot but Skarsgard crawling on all fours
gave me the heebie-jeebies the first
time I watched this anyway these tunnels
have a metal gate at the entrance and
several empty animal cages sitting about
Keith warns tests that someone else is
down there but it's too late as my
ex-girlfriend I mean some sort of
creature rushes from the darkness and
smashes Keith's face straight into the
stone floor without any time to process
that head banger of an Act One Finish
it's seemingly all sunshine and red
convertibles with a beautiful ocean view
and Justin Long's character AJ singing
no no we're just not gonna talk about
that intention that we just saw real
okay we're just gonna keep going he's
singing Donovan's Ricky tiki-tavi
everybody
which is a heavy dose of irony because
the song is supposed to be about
standing up for yourself and facing
problems that seem insurmountable this
ties into later events in the film but
here it's the phone call AJ receives
about him being me too by a co-star on
the pilot that he's working on through
this brief conversation it's very much
established AJ is a scummy guy calling
her a lying bee sting and after further
conversations and meetings no one wants
to deal with him because of this
bombshell that has revealed and is told
no matter what do not contact Megan the
actress that's accusing him of sexual
misconduct AJ has to liquidate some
properties one of which happens to be
located in Detroit ah yes cohesive
storytelling it's all connected man but
here is is another reference to the Riki
tiki-tavi song as the frame is focused
on a snake hanging from the rear view
mirror as AJ parks in front of this view
symbolizing he is a snake no good a sign
of the devil if you want to get extreme
with things meaning these allegations
against him they carry some weight AJ is
a misogynistic narcissist ignoring his
parents bragging to his friend about
what really happened while de-escalating
it like like she was asking for a dude
she wanted it having no regard for
others hilariously chucking Tess's
laptop calling Megan against the advice
he was given and researching the added
property value of the Hidden basement
rooms like some sort of real estate
brochacho rather than being concerned
that there is a freaking snuff room in
your basement what are you doing get out
of that house burn it down sorry AJ is
just a complete idiot as AJ measures his
dick or rather creepy basement added
property square footage he stumbles Upon
A disheveled pinkish room with a small
CRT TV playing a new Mother's baby
nursing video if that's not creepy
enough his tape measure is sucked into
the Dark Void of the basement hallway
and again we see him cowered away from
his problems pulling a knife and running
away Landing in some caged in pit only
to find tests is still alive in the
basement a quick switch to a bright
pastel neighborhood reminiscent of the
one from Edward Scissorhands as we
follow I I gotta say this the
transitions from terrifying
to Bright happiness are amazing anyway
this is Frank living in the same
Nightmare House and through context
clues of Asia's Heat of the Moment
mentions of the Reagan Administration
and then changed for three aspect ratio
this is the early to mid 80s much like
AJ there is this weird connection of
sorts to him in the present events
because of the baby supplies at the
market specifically the same nursing VHS
that is shown earlier Frank's intentions
are further Illustrated as he stalks a
woman from the store posing as a plumber
his name is Carlos that he's not a
Carlos to unlock her window for later
Upon returning to his Nightmare House
his neighbor mentions that the
neighborhood is going belly up Frank
says he's not going anywhere hinting at
him not changing in his ways as screams
from the basement are heard the video
the creature woman Frank something
happened in the past 40 years to bring
us here inferring that Frank was
kidnapping and sexually assaulting these
women in his basement keeping them in
cages and somehow this creature woman is
a byproduct developing an infatuation
with being a mother due to the VHS tape
later on we do discover that
[Music]
though having completely different Paths
of morality Tess and AJ are both caught
in the same situation AJ's ego and
ignorance drives him deeper into the
Madness though refusing to drink from
the hairy nipple I mean how much would
you have to be paid to lick that thing a
hundred bucks come on Tess Escapes in
one of the best and scariest shots of
the woman reaching out only to disappear
into the darkness again the homeless man
Andre helps Tess which he was trying to
warn her about from earlier and that's
not even the worst thing in that house
hint hint Tess's faults are shown even
clearer as she has just saved herself
from this living nightmare but wants to
go back in to save AJ even Andre says
she just needs to worry about herself
test Flags down police that do not
believe her at all thinking that she's
some sort of druggie discount her claims
leaving her alone back at the house AJ
finds another room deep in the basement
that seemingly has someone living in it
the final piece of the puzzle Frank yeah
that dude from the 80s never left the
house instead living in the basement
hint hint the worst thing in the house
AJ's first response is to save the man
that the mother creature is going to pay
for what she did and the cops are going
to be swarming this place don't you
worry until AJ realizes that the man is
actually a sick pervert who had been
essentially assaulting women for decades
filming all of it via VHS tapes AJ's
tone changes dramatically exclaiming
what is wrong with you man you you you
stinky mcstink face resulting in Frank
killing himself the thing about this
scene that is done so perfectly is that
AJ and Frank are one in the same both
hurting people for their own gain or
pleasure not taking into account that
they were essentially monsters AJ
disgusted by Frank's videos but it's him
looking in a mirror both are abusers
blaming others for the situations that
they are in and Frank here doesn't end
his life because he feels guilty about
the last four Decades of abuse no no no
no no no no he ends it because AJ
threatens the cops will show up and he
spins the gears in his mind and thinking
that he'll actually be caught making me
[ __ ] cops swarm in this place real
[ __ ] soon trust me man
Tess unfortunately continues this white
knight Persona slamming her car into the
lanky pale woman making her way back
into the basement to save AJ but this
selflessness is a curse to test
resulting in AJ shooting her it's shown
they are opposites of the same coin Tess
attempts to save the day gets shot
nonchalantly giving the old hey it's
butter flesh wound act the quick shot of
the nursing video implies she is of
nurturing nature while AJ half
apologizes for shooting her and then
refuses to go back in to get the car
keys in the basement even though Tess
just risk her life doing the exact same
thing minutes earlier luckily Andre
gives them shelter filling in a bit of
backstory for the creature woman she's
been living there some 40 years now she
was born there what are you talking
about I own that house somebody lives
there boy you might own that paper but
that's her daddy's house she is a copy
of a copy of a copy you know a Sweet
Home Alabama or the Raw oils inbreeding
situation AJ states that he hurts
someone and that that matters here you
think he's talking about tests because
of the bullet wound from earlier and a
change of heart from his scummy Behavior
but it's actually him referring to the
allegations against him he almost is a
changed person but fixates on the idea
of I need to fix it I can fix it nature
to his problems though like a buck naked
Kool-Aid Man the creature burst through
the wall beating Andre with his own arm
chasing Tess and AJ up to the top of a
silo bin AJ reverts to his old ways
leaving tests behind to fend for herself
panicking that there is nowhere to go
she's never going to stop this is AJ
realizing that there is no way he can
escape the allegations that his co-star
said there's nothing he can do even if
he is innocent it'll tarnish his
reputation but he can buy some time
using a woman as a means without
compassion AJ throws Tess off of the
roof with the creature Woman Andrew
Garfield's Spider-Man diving to save MJ
in a Redemption fashion seeing the
creature save Tess and that Tess is
still alive AJ begins to plead with her
he he had no choice she was going to
kill them both it's something he had to
do you know what you were slipping yeah
yeah I did nothing wrong almost blaming
her again leaning into his scummy
natures and the allegations he's accused
of in his eyes he did nothing wrong just
another person in his path to get what
he wants shockingly though the creature
is still alive crushing in Justin Long's
eyes so that Mr Jeepers Creepers can't
get his peepers then ripping his head
apart AJ be dead the creature tries to
carry tests back to the house with tests
saying she can't she's unable slowly
putting the gun to her Temple and pulls
the trigger boom credits it ends with
The Ronettes Be My Baby which is a
cheeky nod to everything at play here
the creature solely wanted a baby the
whole time with tests being picked as
that baby but unlike the rest of the
movie Tess finally puts her needs first
standing up for herself and lives to see
another day now there are a handful of
different themes and symbolism at play
from beginning to end of Barbarian if
you're wondering why the Barbarian name
to begin with it could be that the
Savage woman was in fact a barbarian in
her constant state of Rage not belonging
to normal society or it could even be a
play on The house's Street of Barberry
but instead themes of abuse trauma
toxicity morality male ego and the
status quo are at play in a rough sense
AJ and Tess are mirrors of Frank and the
mother AJ is an abusive narcissistic
embodying the male toxicity thinking
everything he does is gold well
everything that goes wrong in his life
is blamed on someone else gaslighting is
is that a word we're still using right
now
um AJ is is Dennis from Always Sunny
this is the best exam sample while not
necessarily being threatening from the
outside he is rotten to the core and
evil spreads out of him the idea of an
outside Sheen or brightness can hide
something gross below much like the
house where we know what takes place
inside even comparing Keith and AJ was
set up flawlessly because AJ is
introduced in this flamboyant bright
cheerful manner I mean why wouldn't we
trust this guy he looks like one wild
and crazy guy to hang with until we find
out he's a frat bro uh Chad while Keith
is introduced in a creepy manner it's
late during the thunderstorm a little
awkward is he trying to sleep with Tess
but is soon to found to be trusted
unlike the reputation AJ puts out for a
lot of men heck Keith might actually be
a victim of abuse himself because of his
nightmares and frightful sleep talking
on the other hand Tess is constantly
giving in to people around her with the
quote love and control are the same
thing mentioned earlier when sipping
wine with Keith subtly hinted at by the
constant calls for Marcus in ex-lover
who we can infer kind of had control
over Tess's life and even Keith kind of
telling her hey it's too late to go find
another place just just stay here more
so being ignored by everyone when when
she tells Keith about the basement AJ
about going along with the mother's act
and even the police think that she's
completely crazy and in this constant
putting others before herself mentality
she wound up in this whole mess and got
shot but the last five minutes are when
the status quo changes instead of AJ
getting to live out his days you know
keeping the horrors of his past or
things that he's committed a secret he's
actually killed by a byproduct of what
he would have created the mother if he
would have changed at any point in this
film this could have been avoided
however it was almost a symbol of the
abused getting back at their abuser well
as Tess playing into the song from
earlier Ricky Dicky happy [ __ ] no one
is going to solve your problems instead
you need to learn quote to kill them
yourself now not literally you know
meaning to kill the mother but instead
to stop the constant cycle of giving up
on yourself for others happiness she's
changed for the better I mean if she
didn't kill the mother she would have
submitted like all of the other times
throughout the movie and have been
hauled back to the basement dwelling I'm
not the biggest horror fan but barbarian
was really something different the plot
instantly grabbed me in subverting
expectations was probably its strongest
attribute like I was waiting and waiting
for some cheap jump scare but instead
disregarded the easy ones focusing on
the tension of the scenes to play out
and there are some truly horrifying
imagery the Stark transition from maybe
the most harrowing stuff to bright
colorful happy scenes in an instant
confused my brain in the best way
possible like wait wait we're just not
going to talk about that dude that got
his head smashed in by that monster
woman woman and the flashback scenes
were filmed in such a dream-like
different manner that made me feel like
I was watching an entirely different
movie there was a great use of
atmosphere and lighting as well because
the handful of times that the mother
lurched from the darkness or slowly kind
of receded back into it were brilliant
Barbarian is definitely in my top 10
honestly maybe like top five of the year
and this rewatch allowed me to pick up
on all of these kind of small things
that I missed the first time but yeah
I'd love to hear your thoughts on
Barbarian what were some of your
favorite parts and is this a top tier
horror film of 2022 and I'll let you
know we're currently running a
competition right now giving away three
copies of top gun Maverick on the 15th
of November and all you have to do to
get a chance of winning this is like
this video make sure to subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment Down
Below on what you thought of Barbarian
we picked the comments at random at the
end of the month and the winners of last
month's competition are on screen right
now so if that's you message us on
Twitter at heavy spoilers if you want
something else to watch be sure to check
out some of our other cool videos
whether it be our upcoming DC slate
breakdown or our Constant House of
dragon videos there's dragons check them
out with that out of the way thanks for
your constant support I've been Jared
and I've I've just deleted my Airbnb app
we'll see in the next one take care and
peace